jojo was geht hier ist euer max und
herzlich willkommen zum heutigen video
heute spielen wir eine fussball
challenge das sind ich habe mein bruder
sebastian ihr habt schon hier hinten im
tor hängen sechs titel auf den zetteln
stehen aufgaben wenn jetzt einen echten
zettel treffe dann steht da eine aufgabe
für sebastian drauf und die können
ziemlich unschön sein genau wie schießen
die aufgaben jeweils für den anderen das
heißt wenn ich schieße geht es darum was
max machen muss und wer maxis geht sagen
was ich machen muss 333 schlechte kenner
und diesen noch secret also mit erkennt
nicht was es ist und es hat erst in dem
moment aus gefunden indem wir darauf
schießen getroffen haben os wir schießen
einfach abwechselnd bis alle getroffen
sind und zwar genau von dieser
sonnenbrille auf ihrem papier wer
anfängt jahre gefängnis
ich habe also links rein links unten
nichts getroffen war auch kein treffer
mehr
ja wir nehmen das jetzt abkommen her da
die bestrafung willst du dir anschauen
ist schon gespannt
du darfst ein keks essen
also es war eine der guten sache
der px allergie a [ __ ] das bedeutet
wiederum dass jetzt die
wahrscheinlichkeit dass er was schlecht
ist für mich trifft höher ist ich schau
mir mein lieber das wird seinen gürtel
am donnerstag das ist jetzt ganz stark
sein müsste ein glas wasser trinken
alles karas hat aus habe kein glas trägt
einfach 03 du schaffst es
mit welchen wirbel war für deutsche
botschafter für mich stärker denn je
halter von gott als deutsche em kommt er
machte er machte
15 sekunden freestyle hans alfred haben
wir eine stoppuhr bei 1 kommt kommt herr
step up 5 kommt in mein leben gekommen
oh ja oh ja leute ihr seht es die
rasierschaum shell habe übers wasser
abzuwaschen danach macht es nicht
harmlos
also meine ente auf ok seines
gottverdammten scharfschützen
weil wenn ich hätte wäre würde ich einen
scharfschützen ein eimer eine flasche
eiskaltes wasser bis reggae dafür gerade
frisch abgezockte vorstandes war so vor
zehn 15 minuten und zwar welches das
wasser was ihr im heim haben so breit
wie malaria oder aber kein handy was
irgendwelche wünsche mir die haare da wo
ist also auch um letzten geben
wiederholt wird wiederholung
wiederholung
jetzt bin ich stand was noch passieren
wird nichts
ich würde sagen wir beenden dieses video
ist ziemlich heiß und schwitzt auch
nicht wie ein schwein wehrt euch
gefallen hat lasst doch mal ein like
oder ein abonnement den jungen herren
hier findet ihr in der beschreibung und
ja das was man heute machst du bist du
nicht mal